I think that the European Union has
either been misled or misunderstood
what's in the Belfast agreement so
really what needs to happen is that
there's an understanding of that and
once there's an understanding of that I
think we can deal with the trading
issues through some of the things that
were talked about at that time you will
remember them alternative Arrangements
small business exemptions trusted
Traders is something that I've seen
mentioned again for the first time in in
years so there's a numerous ways we can
deal with the trading issues because of
course the amount of trade that goes
across from Northern Ireland into the
single European market is very very
small when you look at the proportion
compared to the rest of the single
European market but in terms of the GB
to Northern Ireland Market that's our
main Market that's where most of our
Goods circulate within the UK internal
market and therefore that needs to be
remedied